at wikia search what we're really trying
to do is build a freely licensed or
open-source software search engine a
general search engine for the web we're
building on efforts that have been going
on for several years in the nuts project
but we're really committing a lot of
infrastructure to it and programmer time
and the basic idea here is to say that
you know search is the one key piece of
the infrastructure of the internet that
is still very much a proprietary closed
secretive and we want to try to change
that we want to make it open so we're
publishing all the algorithms publishing
all the software so people can see it
but additionally what we're trying to do
is bring in the element of mass
participation user participation the
idea is to take the the normal editorial
decisions that are made within the
search engine company and push those out
into the community as much as possible
so that you know the search results
reflect well whatever this community
things should be ranked in certain ways
so we just launched a very preliminary
alpha version a couple months ago we are
currently very hard at work at version
0.2 which will be releasing within the
next month or two we haven't really
fixed a date yet that's actually
something I need to be working on right
now is my release schedule but yeah
we're really looking forward to getting
that out because there's a lot of cool
new tools and things so
in terms of the user experience we
expect it to be really quite a bit
similar I mean in other words you come
and you type something you're looking
for and you hit search and you get some
stuff back the one major difference at
that point is that you'll be able to
edit the results in essence so you'll be
able to delete things add things and
those are going to be public actions
just as a public when you edit Wikipedia
that's a public action and there'll be a
whole community of people monitoring and
and you know overseeing all that that's
the main difference from the end user
point of view but for me I think the the
deeper implication here is not about
sort of just the user experience but
about the open source nature the free
software nature the way I look at that
for for the average user obviously
you're not going to go and download all
our source code and read it that's
really not that important but what is
important it is as being very similar to
you know free society in an open society
we insist that our court systems operate
in a public fashion so you can go down
to the courthouse today and go in and
and watch a trial unfold and that's done
in public and that's a valuable
safeguard for Human Rights democracy
even though most of us never actually
bother going down to the courthouse but
it's important that there are people who
can and people who do and they'll raise
the alarm if something untoward is going
on and that's really the way it works
with open source software there's also a
lot of practical benefits open source
software which I think we can realize
here you know right now you know
hands-down the best web browser is
Firefox which is an open source project
and you know that's the that development
model for software is proven to be
highly effective one of the things we're
looking at is that there are a lot of
parts of the search business that are
duplicated efforts lots of different
smaller competitors are wasting a lot of
money duplicating a lot of effort to
doing some very basic infrastructure
thing
that are really not necessary to do
multiple times I mean crawling the web
it's a big job but what it means is you
have to go and fetch you know lots and
lots and lots of pages from all over the
internet and it's it's a bit of a
commodity commodity item I mean anyone
can crawl the web it just takes a lot of
engineers and money and time and you
know the techniques for doing it are
pretty robust and well known so what
we're all hoping to do is using the the
social model of free licensing which has
already allowed lots of different
companies to come together you know IBM
contributes a lot to free software Red
Hat you know all these different
companies are working in this space and
they're able to do it because the the
free licensing model creates a level
playing field for that so we're hoping
to see the same kinds of things start to
develop with with search data in other
words having different players share
their crawl results with others freely
so well we're working on that another
part of it is you know one of the things
one of the really interesting that's
going on right now in search is that you
know all of this one of the interesting
things about search that's going on
right now is that all of the the
research and development the vast
majority of it is going on inside
companies and proprietary research
behind closed doors or a secretive at
Google Yahoo ask Microsoft and so forth
and right now if you are a you know a
PhD student in computer science and
you're really interested in search
algorithms it's kind of hard for you to
really get involved and to work on
things because you don't have access to
the kind of resources that you would
like to have and so a big part of what I
want to do is is say well look if we
make all the source code open-source any
of those people can download it they can
run out on a university cluster we're
going to try to make available research
machines for people to run things just
to do experimentation just to sort of
say let's let's try to you know use the
time-honored and tested methods of
academic research where things are done
publicly under peer review
and and really for let's provide some
infrastructure for that so that's kind
of the idea there